ça tu vois ce que tu vas me dire c'est
un sujet de dissert c'est je pourrais
t'en je pourrais faire une dissert de
trois heures Clem il dit c'est un peu de
la mauvaise foi quand je dis que c'est
nul que je suis nul et cetera mais des
fois c'est pas de la mauvaise foi dans
le sens où c'est vraiment nul ce que
j'ai fait moi je me mets pas mal pour
écrire c'est j'essaye d'écrire et ça me
met mal et puis de toute façon qu'est-ce
que c'est des polémiques maintenant tu
vas voir 15 articles on sait même pas si
les gens les lisent
[Musique]
avec du monde autour
ce qui est intéressant dans le doc c'est
que nous d'habitude on a on voit entre
guillemets le produit fini le travail de
ta création là on voit tout c'est à dire
tes doutes aussi et est-ce que quelque
part le doute c'est c'est nécessaire
pour la création pour être pour être à
l'aise pour pour trouver ses idées la
remise en cause et elle est obligatoire
bah je pense que oui pour faire de la
création bien oui et puis surtout quand
tu commences à être à ton quatrième
cinquième album un moment
faut se remettre en question ouais bien
sûr parce que
souvent on a tendance à croire que genre
les artistes sont des génies qui sortent
des trucs comme ça mais peut-être une
fois de temps en temps mais la plupart
du temps en tout cas moi ce que je fais
80% et pas bien et après faut faire le
tri dedans
de nouveaux univers au rêve j'entends
toujours écouter des nouvelles musiques
tu vois il écoute jamais des anciens
albums pas les siens mais de même des
albums qu'il a vraiment kiffé tu vois je
sais pas
avec la main il écoute toujours des
trucs nouvelles envie d'aller chercher
ailleurs trouver des nouvelles
influences toi qu'est-ce que j'ai pas
fait donc bah par exemple au début je
savais que ça allait être un truc
nouveau mais
tant que ça existe pas tu te dis mais
qu'est-ce qui va trouver comment il va
faire quoi tu vois ça c'est assez ouf à
filmer à avoir quoi parce que justement
tu dis que tu écoutes beaucoup de choses
c'est quoi tes influences un petit peu
justement dans ton processus de création
moi ça dépend ça change tout le temps
justement dans le même dans le même
album je vais avoir cinq périodes
différentes et en fonction mais j'écoute
quand même beaucoup de nouvelles
musiques ça veut dire
ça peut arriver une fois de temps en
temps que je me remette un peu des
classiques tu vois je sais pas des
années 80 ou des classiques du rap des
années 90 mais c'est pas du tout la
musique que j'écoute tous les jours quoi
souvent j'ai envie de je suis curieux
j'ai envie de connaître des nouveaux
artistes j'ai envie de connaître des
nouveaux courants et forcément vu que
c'est ça qui influence ma musique je
vais avoir envie de
ouais de m'inspirer ça quoi et c'est
quand même un beaucoup d'aller-retour
entre des trucs du passé et des trucs du
présent voir du futur tu as toujours eu
les Anglais quoi l'Angleterre la Graille
il y a eu des trucs
ça suit une ligne directrice dire à la
base c'était un gros fan de graines
maintenant j'écoute beaucoup de Deal
anglaise quoi ce qui est un peu le la
continuité de trucs mais
un moment dans l'album j'écoutais
beaucoup d'électro un moment c'est un
peu c'est pas tout à fait ce que j'ai
raconté juste avant mais à un moment
j'écoutais les Daft à fond
à un moment ouais ça dépend après il y a
toujours un moment où je réécoute du
Kendrick il y a toujours un moment où
mais j'ai quand même envie de faire une
musique un peu différente
je trouve souvent c'est parce que tu
cherches enfin c'est aussi parfois même
c'est marrant c'est par plaisir mais
c'est aussi comme ils ont fait tu vas
les rechercher leur secret tu reprends
du plaisir mais je te voyais souvent
chercher quoi ouais ouais j'écoute plus
c'est un mélange de oui aller rechercher
me dire tiens j'aimais bien ce morceau
j'aimerais bien
recréer la vibe de ce morceau c'est un
mélange de ça et après tu sais pas
pourquoi tu allumes la radio ou je coupe
pas mal les radios anglaises genre je
sais pas rince ou BBC ou un extra et tu
tombes sur un truc tu tombes sur un je
sais pas et Diwan frais de gaine et tu
me diras c'est c'est un nouveau truc et
c'est vrai que c'est un mélange toujours
entre aller chercher des nouveaux trucs
et des trucs qui tombent dessus par
hasard quoi quand je vois le doc on
ressent par moments un sentiment de de
tristesse voir parfois même de
dépression chez toi
est-ce que tu peux un peu nous expliquer
voilà les les moments parfois un peu
compliqués quoi parce que c'est vrai que
dans la créa il y a des moments où tu on
parlais du doute mais il y a aussi des
moments où se doute peut entraîner des
sentiments parfois négatifs il y a le
confinement aussi
besoin d'un observateur extérieur
comment tu vas ressenti toi c'est des
des sensations passagères qui
d'autre s'il a besoin en fait pour aller
chercher des émotions déjà et puis il y
a un petit peu de mauvaise foi aussi
parce que quelque part je pense qu'en
réalité je suis pas fait pour ça je
descends aussi bas que je suis monté oh
[ __ ] de merde je trouve tout nul
je me suis trompé de branches je chante
faux et je sais pas faire des musiques
c'est un peu la facilité tu dis bon bah
au moins c'est normal que j'ai raté mon
morceau que j'ai essayé les deux
dernières semaines de toute façon je
suis pas fait pour ça mais en fait après
tu redeviens un petit peu lucide et puis
tu te dis tu te dis non non en fait
vas-y boisson mais parce que là ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai bien aimé avec un tout
petit peu de
commentaires parce que j'ai bien aimé
c'est en fait Aurel il même si c'est que
moi on est que deux dans une pièce il y
a quand même un petit sentiment de se
jeter dans le vide quand il fait un
morceau quand il chante quand il pousse
la chanson tout le monde qui a fait un
karaoké une fois se sent complètement
con d'avoir chanté à tue-tête du Céline
Dion alors qu'en fait il y a rien de
grave en fait c'est pas très grave mais
en vrai elle est un peu cette ce
sentiment là et donc quand tu t'es mis
un peu à nu même c'est juste face à moi
et à la caméra quand c'est pas bien
après tu as un peu honte t'es pas bien
tu dis mais pourquoi j'ai fait ça
une chanson que tu as pas composé et
tout c'est plus gentil tu réfléchis
comment dire tu vas ouais un peu de
t'exposer toi ta vie je vais essayer de
chercher dans le fin fond de mes
sentiments pour pour sortir un truc
intéressant et puis
et puis
quand c'est pas bien tu te dis mais en
fait je suis pas intéressante ouais
exactement
en fait Clem il dit c'est un peu de la
mauvaise foi quand je dis que c'est nul
que je suis nul etc mais des fois c'est
pas de la mauvaise foi dans le sens où
c'est vraiment nul ce que j'ai fait il y
a pas de tu vois ce que je veux les
trois premiers pas les trois premiers
mots on va dire des fois je vais passer
deux semaines genre pour faire un
morceau comme on voit dans le doc à un
moment je fais je suis un morceau c'est
le premier je suis à fond je me dis ça
va être génial je m'enflamme et quand je
me dis ça va être génial ce dash
j'imagine tout de suite le clip
j'imagine tout de suite la tournée il y
a sûrement une part de mon ego qui
imagine le moment où il va y avoir un
commentaire et vous dire il a tout
compris et en fait tu écoutes et tu as
rien compris et vraiment c'est juste pas
bien et donc tu as honte en fait et le
retour à la réalité est dur quoi puisque
quelque part on est obligé de se mettre
un peu un peu mal dans ses convictions
dans son talent pour aller aussi loin
dans le processus de création
tu me fais pas pour écrire je crois pas
ah c'est la raison c'est le résultat
quand c'est pas à la hauteur de tes
attentes je crois pas que tu te mettes
mal pour écrire quoi ah oui non moi je
me mets pas mal pour écrire c'est
j'essaye d'écrire et ça me met mal ça
c'est sûr moi si j'ai le choix
j'aimerais bien c'est ce que je dis à un
moment dans le dogue mais j'ai pas envie
d'être dans cet état là moi je veux
trouver la solution et le délire c'est
non je fais pas puiser mon inspiration
non la mélancolie telle un philosophe du
19e
[Musique]
poète maudit ça c'est sûr ce que je veux
dire c'est que je pense par contre pour
en avoir parlé avec d'autres gens qui
écrivent des trucs je pense que un
moment si tu veux faire un bon projet il
va falloir se remettre en question il va
falloir aller puiser dans des émotions
pas je pense souvent cet exemple par
exemple dans la chanson la quête que
genre une chanson qui a bien marché de
l'album et que genre qui qu'une chanson
un peu elle est gentille tu vois et ben
je raconte quand même des trucs qui sont
des traumas que j'ai eu genre par
exemple un moment je dis j'abandonne
lâchement tous mes potes et tout c'est
un truc que j'ai fait genre quand
j'étais en quatrième je suis tombé
[Musique]
à fond fume des clopes j'y pense encore
maintenant et je pense qu'il faut se
replonger dans ses émotions pour aller
chercher un peu des émotions justement
ton inspiration elle vient des émotions
des moments que tu as vécu ou alors
c'est un peu tiens j'ai vécu un truc sur
l'instant présent là je pense ce soir il
faut que j'écrive c'est le contraire
justement ça vient plus justement Clem
un moment et il a il l'a mis dans le doc
un passage où je dis j'ai l'impression
de vivre les émotions à retardement
c'est moi j'arrive pas forcément à
écrire tu vois il m'arrive un truc
j'avais vu une interview de Bob Dylan où
il disait je sais pas il s'est fait
genre il y a un réceptionniste qui lui a
mal parlé il est parti dans sa chambre
c'est plus grands pamphlet qui n'a rien
à voir le réceptionniste et c'est pour
ça aussi on a pas mal vu les images du
mariage d'Aurélie et tout sur les amis
c'est parce qu'à un moment ça
ça avoir avec la création en fait ça
raconte quelque chose et Orel il a mis
un mois à le mettre dans une chanson
c'est pas le soir même de ta lune de
miel où tu dis oui je vais raconter ce
formidable moment que j'avais même dit
mais après il y a des artistes qui font
très bien il y a plein d'artistes qui
sont méga spontanés surtout maintenant
dans la musique actuelle et tout ils
vont au studio ils te sortent le truc de
la journée et ça défonce parce qu'ils
ont mis cette vibe et même moi ça m'est
déjà arrivé il y a des morceaux je les
ai il y a quand même des morceaux que
j'ai fait en quatre heures et qui était
bien c'est juste je prends ça plus comme
des exceptions quoi
quand on parle justement de la remise en
cause des doutes il y avait ton
producteur qui qui disait justement dans
la musique c'est facile de percer mais
c'est difficile de rester ce que toi
c'est quelque chose que qui te guide un
peu au quotidien
ouais c'est un black qui dit ça et de
c'est facile de percer c'est difficile
de rester
c'est complètement vrai ouais c'est je
pense que souvent tu vas percer parce
que tu amènes une fraîcheur qui est un
peu naturel tu as pas besoin d'aller
renouveler ta musique tu as aussi les
inspi du moment parce que tu amènes une
nouvelle culture des nouvelles inspides
des nouvelles une nouvelle vibes qui est
fraîche tandis que pour rester il faut
pas faire la même chose tout en faisant
un peu la chose pour lesquelles on
t'aime et continuer
c'est vraiment vrai dans la musique plus
que peut-être dans la littérature ou
dans le cinéma dans la musique il y a
beaucoup d'artistes qui qui n'arrivent
pas à le faire longtemps parce que c'est
dur et même moi je me pose tout le temps
cette question si je refais un album un
jour je vais avoir ça va être dur et je
vais me dire que ça va peut-être être
nul quoi tu dis même j'étais très bien
dans ma vie pourquoi je refais un album
je comprends Goldman pourquoi il a tout
arrêté est-ce que tout a déjà
je reprends est-ce que toi tu as déjà
songé à tout arrêter je songe à tout
arrêter à chaque instant même là par
exemple je suis en interview je me dis
mais pourquoi je suis là ça n'a pas je
remets tout en question tout le temps en
fait et en plus j'ai plein d'autres
passions et tout ça ça me dérangerait
pas d'arrêter sur le moment précis mais
je sais que je le regretterai en plus
j'ai trop marrant parce qu'il dit ça et
j'étais très bien dans ma vie pourquoi
j'ai voulu mais en fait sa vie à trois
mois avant c'était la même chose en fait
c'était déjà c'est tout parce que je
veux dire il s'arrête jamais de taffer
en fait donc il dit ça sur le moment
c'est même pas vrai puisque en fait
avant il était en tournée et avant
il y a quelqu'un une fois qu'il a posé
la question mais tu fais pas entre tes
albums en fait ce que tu parles
longtemps mais en fait entre ces albums
Aurel il tourne et puis après il refait
un autre album il y a pas de
la tournée il fait 1000 autres trucs
donc même quand il dit ça dans la
cuisine à ce moment-là en fait il se
ment à lui-même parce que un an avant il
était en train de taper comme là je dis
pourquoi je suis je suis là alors qu'en
fait je suis là parce qu'on a fait un
doc qui est cool et j'ai envie que les
gens le voient mais il y a quand même un
moment où tu es face à tes doutes tu es
face à ouais tu as envie d'arrêter oui
c'est sûr bien sûr tous les artistes ont
envie d'arrêter puis des fois tu as
juste envie aussi de de changer mais en
fait la vérité c'est que tu as souvent
envie de faire une pause parce que tu
parles de pause est-ce que tu as déjà tu
t'es déjà dit moi moi à cet âge là je
vais arrêter ma carrière
ouais bien sûr quand j'avais je me
rappelle quand j'avais écrit un texte
sur quand j'avais 22 ans vous le disait
quand je vois des artistes qu'on dépassé
la trentaine je suis mort de rire en
tout cas c'est dans ma tête aujourd'hui
c'est quoi il y a un album que
j'écoutais pas mal il y a 2 ans là qui
s'appelle c'est un artiste qui s'appelle
Slumdog qui a fait un album assez cool
de de gens qui s'appelle love lost and
autotune comme ça il y a un feat avec
bonne hiver et genre il a 82 ans et
genre il a sorti un album que j'écoutais
qui était frais et je me suis dit cool
tu vois c'est juste par contre j'ai pas
envie de refaire tout le temps la même
chose tu vois j'ai pas envie de
m'enfermer dans un cycle album
tourné album tourné et puis me perdre
là-dedans quoi j'ai envie de garder du
plaisir et j'ai envie de faire d'autres
choses aussi et donc 10 15 ans justement
tu ferais quoi on verra tu as des idées
un peu en tête des projets justement je
trouve ça un peu je passe spécialement
envie de me projeter là j'ai la tournée
j'ai envie de profiter de la tournée il
me reste encore une trentaine de dates
j'ai envie de profiter de cette date-là
d'être genre vraiment dans dans le
moment d'être de faire mes morceaux et
puis j'ai envie peut-être ouais
justement de arrêter de flipper déjà ça
pourrait être bien arrêter de me
remettre en question
ou un art floral ou à tu vois ce que je
veux dire ou aux échecs et de se dire si
je devenais professionnel
est-ce qu'il y a des moments où vous
dites bah non je pense que ni l'un ni
l'autre ça va le faire est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment eu des doutes parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de l'album au niveau du dock je
pense que des fois il y a des moments
dit est-ce que parce que les conditions
de tournage c'est pas évident c'est
pendant le confinement etc
en plus déjà il y a un truc hyper relou
pour un documentaire c'est les masques
parce que tu vois jamais les visages des
gens c'est très relou c'est con
ouais en fait c'était marrant parce que
donc moi j'ai en fait c'est pas j'ai
commencé à retourner une fois que le doc
l'année dernière est sorti je continue à
tourner pendant que je montais les
épisodes de la de la première partie et
donc j'étais toujours un peu dans le
dans le tambour de de la machine quoi et
puis et je me suis posé des questions
j'étais beaucoup en miroir avec mon
frère en fait Aurel il galère un peu sur
l'album moi je ramenais des rushs et
j'essayais de monter et je et je
galérais aussi à les monter pour que ce
soit bien je me disais mais est-ce que
les gens ils ont envie d'entendre parler
de de création est-ce que ça va
intéresser les gens vraiment horrible
que tu as coupé tu peux nous en parler
des moments que j'ai coupé j'ai failli
couper le moment où j'essaie de sauver
au elle en écrivant un couplet ça simule
si les gars m'avait pas dit non non
c'est bien les monteurs Hugo ml et
Christophe et qui j'ai co réalisé
non qu'est-ce que j'ai coupé qui était
pas bien non un peu comme comme dans
tout projet des trucs trop qui ne sont
pas universels en fait trop privés et
donc peu intéressant tout ce qui était
pas en lien avec la création d'un album
tout seul
ouais j'aime bien c'est un peu moins non
moi je enfin je monte tout seul et je
montrais à Aurel à Blaye scred il aimait
Aurel chez vous deux fois les épisodes
quoi bah même il y a encore euh j'ai
même pas vu les dernières années
[Rires]
c'est pas retirer en fait non parce
qu'en fait non je vois cette question
genre qu'est-ce qu'on montre pas mais en
fait moi les les retours que j'ai en
général ils sont vraiment centrés sur la
narration et j'ai envie que ce soit bien
en fait c'est à dire il y a des moments
j'aime pas me voir il y a des moments
par exemple avec les petites crèmes je
vois que je suis un peu gêné par leur
présence où il y a des moments où je
suis en galère ou quand j'appelle Apple
pour moi je suis pas à mon avantage mais
dans l'histoire c'est fun donc au
contraire je me dis mets ton lait et par
exemple j'ai j'ai plus fait de retour
sur là on s'ennuie aux gens ça je trouve
que c'est pas important peut-être là
surtout par rapport au morceau là
j'aurais peut-être mis plus de maquettes
parce que cette maquette va amener ça
mais les retours que j'ai fait ils sont
vraiment sur l'histoire parce qu'en fait
moi je veux dire c'est aussi logique
plus les épisodes sont bien mieux je
vais en sortir peu importe
c'est pas la séquence individuelle où tu
vas briller
c'est assez fou d'ailleurs parce qu'il
arrivait à avoir les épisodes comme un
documentaire sur presque quelqu'un
d'autre en fait il me faisait des
retours comme si c'était pas lui qui
était à l'écran quoi donc c'était des
trucs pour améliorer les épisodes après
ouais tu les as pas vu beaucoup les
seuls trucs par exemple tu vois il y a
mon mariage dans le doc si Clem avant de
l'avoir fait il m'avait dit et là il y
aura ton mariage dans le dos j'aurais
dit ouais ça va peser ce qui est
vraiment un peu en train de se passer
c'est vrai qu'il me voit très peu ta vie
privée finalement et là il y a le
mariage donc c'est quoi l'incidence
finalement par rapport à la à la créa à
ce que tu veux montrer justement c'est
Clem avait dit et à le mariage dans le
doc avant je pense que j'aurais dit non
sur le papier et il m'a montré l'épisode
fini avec le mariage et il va vous
expliquer pourquoi il l'a mis et par
exemple donc je l'ai mis parce que donc
c'est en rapport à la chanson la quête
dans laquelle elle parle de son mariage
il voulait conclure sa chanson en
trouvant un moment justement où il sent
bien où il a pas envie d'aller chercher
plus loin dans la chanson la quête c'est
toujours en train de chercher le moment
d'après où il va se sentir bien et en
fait ce mariage qui à la base est un
moment un peu stressant en plus qu'il
coupait dans l'album et tout après
l'avoir digéré était ce moment où il
sentait bien qu'il a utilisé dans le
dernier couplet de la quête pour
débloquer et terminer sa chanson donc
dans la construction de l'album c'était
hyper intéressant et en vrai on parle du
Majorelle il y a il y a 10 plans demain
enfin c'est pas non plus on voit pas la
préparation et le choix des fleurs parce
que c'est des études
et puis une fois qu'il m'a montré une
fois qu'il m'a montré les images je
trouvais que ça faisait une bonne
séquence en fait aussi en vrai
finalement à ma vie privée elle est
mélangée avec ma musique je veux dire
c'est pas de la fiction il y a mes vrais
potes dedans il y a donc au final je
trouvais que ça faisait partie de
l'histoire de raconter qu'un moment il y
avait aussi des trucs en famille et puis
et puis les images sont cool donc
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé que c'était
opportun tu vois peut-être je le
regretterai
soit c'est un cycle qui est quand même
très prenant la créa après on s'expose
au public la tournée aussi c'est
fatigant est-ce que des fois tu as pas
une sorte de Burn Out clairement parce
qu'on sait que c'est parfois un terme un
peu ta bouche et les artistes et que toi
tu t'es dit bah des fois ouais ça m'est
arrivé j'étais vraiment mal est-ce qu'il
y a des moments comme ça bah non dans la
saison 1 du doc on voit qu'après les
polémiques et tout je suis un peu je
suis plus en requestionnant et limite je
dirais pas Bernard je dirais limite mini
déprime quoi c'est mais je m'en suis
rendu compte après et là burnout ouais
ça m'arrive je suis vraiment pas loin
des fois à la batterie du la batterie
sur le téléphone a commencé à clignoter
je verrai pas la batterie sur le
téléphone je vois genre l'aiguille qui
commence à taper dans la route
et des fois je dois faire gaffe parce
que je me rapproche c'est je pense que
les burn-out c'est même dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est quand tu es à fond
sur plusieurs projets et tout d'un coup
tu as tous les projets en même temps et
ça inclut aussi ta life et à la fin en
vrai moi je vois sur les images par
exemple c'est des images où je me trouve
pas mon avantage parce que je suis
vraiment en doute et je suis vraiment
genre faut rendre l'album et en même
temps j'ai j'ai ma vie privée en même
temps j'ai ma marque de vêtements en
même temps on est en promo pour le doc
bah physiquement tu étais marqué et moi
c'est ce que je raconte dans le doc
c'est que à un moment pendant toute la
phase de création c'est c'est assez fun
et marrant et à des moments plus tendus
que d'autres et tout mais on s'amuse et
même quand il est en galère ça me fait
rigoler quand il arrive vraiment au bout
physiquement et que tu vois que il
allait jouer et qu'en plus on va par
exemple on va faire des plateaux pour
vendre le doc parce qu'on est content de
ce qu'on a fait et tout et que je vois
que ma partie préférée du tout ou
souvent il est mal à l'aise et tout et
bah et là là je m'inquiète un peu je me
dis ouais voilà on commence à tirer sur
le physique et puis sur le sur le
psychologique et tout parce que
évidemment
et que avec tout ce succès comment tu
arrives à te détacher un peu de tout ça
voilà par exemple on te voit aussi faire
tes courses ça peut paraître anodin mais
pour rester un peu dans la dans la vie
de monsieur madame tout le monde quoi
moi je pense c'est vraiment une question
d'entourage même par rapport au burn-out
moi je pense que j'ai pas vraiment fait
de Burn Out et que parce que j'ai un
entourage cholé avec scred à Blaye qui
sont là Clem et que on se répartit un
peu les tâches et la pression tu vois je
pense que c'est aussi être conscient
avoir conscience de
ton statut un peu par exemple moi faire
les courses en fait je veux dire j'ai
pas envie d'être dans le cliché de de la
star des années 90 qui qui a plus de
live en fait ça veut dire moi pour moi
c'est plus simple d'aller faire les
courses quand je dois faire les courses
que appeler quelqu'un pour faire tes
courses enfin je sais pas c'est bizarre
donc du coup je pense que ouais aussi tu
quand tu es connu et tout je pense que
quand tu essayes d'être ce que tu crois
que tu dois être c'est là où ça commence
à créer un décalage et moi en fait je
vais faire mes courses oui bah il y a
des qui vont me prendre en photo et tout
mais déjà là franchement 99 des gens
sont archi cool c'est un peu plus long
et puis au final ouais je pense ouais
mais si ça va être quand même à pas à
pas devenir ouf quoi et pas devenir
rouge j'imagine que c'est parfois aussi
se déconnecter de Paris enfin moi je
prends l'exemple je suis journaliste
Paris il y a beaucoup de boulot ici et
quand on veut se ressourcer des fois
c'est bien d'aller dans le petit village
voilà moi je viens du Nord de la France
je vais voir mes parents on ça détend un
peu s'éloigne un peu de se faire là pour
toi c'est la même chose
représenté quand et Alençon aussi parce
qu'en vrai on est arrivé à Caen au
milieu de notre adolescence quoi donc
c'est des villes tu peux pas tu viens de
là-bas quoi tu vois quand tu habites à
Paris tu croises beaucoup de gens en
fait qui sont pas des Parisiens tu sais
des Roannais des Grenoblois et des des
Lillois tu vois tu tout le monde reste
un peu un moi là par exemple ça fait
bientôt 10 ans que j'habite à Paris mes
enfants ils sont nés à Paris mais j'ai
la je dis toujours bon quand est-ce la
dans deux semaines on rentre à Caen tu
vois ce que je dis au même à mes enfants
et tout donc tu restes toujours un peu
un petit peu ça fait du bien c'est
pareil c'est en gros la vie pro et quand
les petits perso
j'habite plus à Caen qu'à Paris je suis
sur Paris parce que c'est de la ou pas
le tourbus pour la tournée et c'est là
où je fais des interviews en gros mais
la plupart du temps je suis quand même à
Caen après il y a pas que la situation
géographique par exemple pendant l'album
j'ai coupé les réseaux même je gère
différemment mon rapport à Twitter insta
et tout ça veut dire en gros ils sont
sur mon iPad et j'y vais une fois de
temps en temps une fois par semaine
comme je pourrais regarder une série tu
vois les commentaires sur les réseaux je
lis les commentaires ça fait longtemps
que j'ai pas lu les commentaires mais si
je les lis en période de sortie de
projet tu vois si je sors un clip je
vais aller voir peut-être les deux
premières heures ou peut-être je vais
aller
si je sors par exemple quand le doc il
va sortir je pense à un moment je vais y
aller franchement c'est comment tu vis
ça justement parce que tu as le
processus ou pendant des mois tu vas
créer parfois plus là ça tombe dans les
mains du grand public avec tout ce que
ça de bon et moi bon parfois parce que
les réseaux des fois c'est ça peut aussi
être violent aussi ouais ça peut ça peut
complètement être violent mais après euh
mais après je clique sur la photo de
profil et je me dis mais pourquoi
j'écoute
si elle venait me voir dans la vraie vie
je me dirais juste mais mais non et puis
en fait je sais pas j'ai l'habitude
c'est juste moi les réseaux c'est pas
trop les commentaires qui me gênent dans
le sens où déjà les gens sont quand même
assez cool avec moi et tout même les
mêmes je suis quand même une bonne usine
à même et à la rigueur c'est pas trop ça
non c'est plus en fait c'est plus l'info
qui vient des réseaux je veux dire même
les commentaires des fois je vais me
poser des questions j'ai pas à me les
poser en fait c'est comme j'arrive pas à
recevoir plein d'informations et juste
dire ah oui à ça ah oui il y a ça ah oui
ah ça j'aime bien quand je reçois une
information qui vient d'un stade ou de
n'importe où j'aime bien y réfléchir à
me poser ça me touche en fait et donc du
coup
je me rappelle quand
il y a un des sons qui est sorti je sais
plus ce que c'était tu as lu en fait
Aurel et ça doit être l'odeur de
l'essence par exemple et Aurelle
commence à aller à les commentaires
parce que tu me fais quoi un quart
d'heure et en fait il y a un truc c'est
chiant mais le truc d'après c'est éclaté
le tweet c'est de l'électro et là tu vas
dire c'est de la drill et là aurait fait
ok bon allez c'est n'importe quoi il y a
tous les avis et tout donc je ferme il
faut faire le tri il faut prendre un peu
de recul quoi en fait tous les avis sont
exprimés donc en fait tu dis ouais ouais
à quel moment tu as envie d'avoir tous
les avis de tout le temps en même temps
et
dans le seul truc c'est par exemple moi
l'odeur de l'essence je pensais pas que
ce serait un morceau qui était aussi
politisé que ça tu vois et ça a vite
pris des ampleurs ouais un peu politique
où tout le monde y mettait un peu ce
qu'il voulait quoi
il y a beaucoup de trucs avec lesquels
je suis pas d'accord c'est à dire je
vais le lire je vais avoir une réaction
un peu et après je vais devoir me poser
me dire alors pourquoi je suis pas
d'accord avec ce truc et c'est du temps
de cerveau quoi
[Musique]
mais notamment quand tu parles de du
côté politique tu écris un titre de 7
minutes avec en fond sonore des
manifestations alors moi ça m'a parlé
parce que je couvre énormément pour brut
pour la prochaine fois je te filme même
mes images de manifs il y a pas de souci
mais je me disais justement est-ce qu'il
y a il y a une fibre derrière parce que
je me dis voilà on va récupérer des
images des sonores de manifestations
c'est est-ce que ce qui est le fond même
de ces manifestations ça t'intéresse les
messages portés
oui oui ça m'intéresse après moi j'ai du
mal à moi je me considère vraiment comme
un
artiste des j'aime bien voir tous les
points de vue je dirais j'arrive pas à
avoir un point de vue c'est pour ça
aussi que je donne pas forcément j'ai
des points de vue un peu de base tu vois
mais j'ai vachement de mal à être
certain d'une idée je veux entendre un
avis je vais être d'accord j'entends un
autre avis je vais être d'accord je vais
peser le pour et le contre et ça
m'intéresse même pas spécialement en
tout cas dans mon rôle d'artiste
d'avoir j'aime c'est pour ça que ma
chanson sur la manif en fait je prends
différents personnages parce que
j'aimais bien voir un peu quelqu'un qui
va être super engagé quelqu'un qui est
là parce que il a envie de sortir avec
la personne super engagée quelqu'un qui
passe par hasard et puis quelqu'un qui
est vraiment concerné par le problème en
fait le problème c'est que souvent comme
beaucoup de sujets de la société
actuelle c'est des sujets hyper
complexes et bien sûr ça pourrait
m'intéresser il y a plein de sujets sur
lesquels je me suis penché pour écrire
l'album ou même sujet aujourd'hui que tu
portes et que tu as envie de porter à
l'avenir parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
on pense beaucoup aujourd'hui à la
jeunesse qui a envie de voir ces
artistes favoris porter des sujets
importants sur l'environnement sur le
féminisme d'autres sujets aussi sur des
sujets sociaux aussi ouais bah le sujet
je pense je l'ai pas déjà dans dans mes
morceaux tu vois c'est juste j'essaye
d'amener un peu par exemple j'ai galéré
sur l'album pour faire une chanson sur
l'écologie que j'avais envie de faire
une chanson sur l'écologie et un peu
comme tout le monde je me sentais pas
légitime je me sentais je savais pas
quoi faire j'ai très peu d'exemples de
chansons écologiques qui sont cool tu
vois je pourrais peut-être en citer deux
ou trois mais c'est souvent un peu
moralisateur et puis
je sais pas c'est souvent la musique
c'est pour se divertir et donc
finalement j'ai fini par faire une
chanson genre je suis dans une soirée où
j'ai envie justement me divertir et
finalement je commence à un peu suivre
le fil des choses c'est à dire je suis
un gobelet en plastique je vois d'où il
vient du coup ça me nique ma soirée
après je suis carrément un vêtement sur
genre toute la chaîne de production un
survêt sur toute la chaîne de production
et donc pour moi ça c'est c'est ma façon
de m'engager je pense que ça pourrait
être aussi être présent dans un cortège
par exemple dans un cantèle de manif par
exemple une manif pour le climax qu'on
pourrait dire ben un jour Orelsan il va
être je sais pas pourquoi pas oui c'est
pas vraiment je me suis même pas posé la
question tu vois parce que pour moi
pour moi oui c'est bien d'être présent
dans un cortège ça peut ça peut être
bien mais c'est aussi bien de faire des
chansons tu vois par exemple là j'ai un
projet en ce moment à Madagascar ou on a
choisi de d'essayer d'aider des artistes
dans ma tête je me vois vraiment comme
ma spécialité pour l'instant en tout cas
de ce que je maîtrise c'est un peu la
musique le cinéma l'écriture donc j'ai
envie d'apporter des choses par rapport
à ça tu vois après le reste elle est
dans une manif c'est quoi je me suis
jamais posé la question je peux pas te
répondre c'est ça dépend du contexte ça
dépend du truc en plus tu vois Aurel là
où moi c'était un exemple pour moi c'est
je dis va pas faire des grands discours
en tant que Aurélien il va pas te dire
quoi faire il va pas te
pas t'expliquer la vie par contre dans
ses chansons et ça a beau être mon grand
frère c'est aussi un mes rappeur préféré
il va me mettre le doigt sur des
mécanismes qui vont être le début de ma
propre réflexion que après je peux me
faire en allant lire des bouquins en on
a un plan de monde et auraient pour moi
il a souvent servi à ça à déconstruire
les choses à te dire ah ouais tiens on
fait ça pourquoi on fait ça c'est normal
qu'on fasse ça pourquoi est-ce que on
pourrait pas faire différemment et après
à toi d'aller chercher tes réponses
déconstruire les choses et même Macron
qui font on aurait le sein d'un très bon
sociologue de la société d'aujourd'hui
vous en pensez quoi tous les deux
c'est toujours difficile à répondre
parce que d'un côté tu es toujours
flatté quand quelqu'un dit que que ta
musique et bien et puis en plus il me
dit pas comme un sociologue donc je sais
il y a forcément mon ego qui s'appelait
plaisir tu vois et d'un autre côté et
puis aussi parce que c'est président
donc je pense à mes parents qui vont
dire le président de la République bien
aimé ta musique donc ça fait plaisir
après dans notre côté ça tu sais que
dans les médias ça va faire que tout le
monde va interpréter le truc n'importe
comment donc tu as même pas envie de
politique quoi
aussi en fait c'est des émotions
mélangées je peux pas limite ça tu vois
ce que tu vas me dire c'est un sujet dis
certes c'est je pourrais t'en je
pourrais faire une dissert de trois
heures dessus mais j'ai pas envie de
t'en parler en une minute comme ça déjà
parce que je vais regretter parce que je
pourrais avoir des arguments encore
mieux que ça c'est un très bon sujet de
bug philo pour l'année prochaine
c'est le mot c'est
de décortiquer donc donc ouais tu vois
un sociologue c'est un quelqu'un de
c'est un chercheur en fait je le vois
comme ça comme un chercheur qui va
décortiquer des choses près de manière
un peu statistique un peu froide après
c'est pas pour ça que tu vas forcément
et toi tu as déjà échangé avec le
président sur ça non jamais mais juste
président justement j'essaye de pas du
tout de pas du tout moi je fais de la
musique j'essaie de faire ma musique le
mieux possible et après justement si je
trouve que quand même un des problèmes
en ce moment c'est ce que j'étais dans
le dans l'essence c'est quand même que
tout le monde parle de tout et n'importe
quoi et moi je suis je suis quand même
plus j'aime bien aussi avoir un peu de
recul par rapport à ça pour pouvoir
prendre les émotions les remettre dans
la musique et je suis pas en fait je m'y
connais pas bien en politique je pense
même pas comment on avis sur ce sujet à
mon avis sur ce sujet précis et je pense
en bus très compliqué je suis un peu sûr
qu'il soit bon donc je vais dire on s'en
fout moi je préfère genre prendre tout
ça le mettre dans un peu dans un tamis
et le est sortir un peu l'odeur de
l'essence tu vois et après les ces gens
interprétés je pense que c'est que ce
sera la chanson qui va aspirer quelqu'un
dans son domaine où il sera fort ce sera
à la politique exactement le plus long
au moins tuer des politiques mieux c'est
pour toi quoi vraiment moi pour
l'instant en tout cas personne en tout
cas j'ai pas ouais pour l'instant perso
en tout cas j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
vision ouais je pour l'instant ouais je
me contente dans mon rôle d'artiste et
j'essaie pas de je sais pas du tout de
faire de la politique quoi après
tu me demandes si je pourrais aller dans
une manip plus tard je veux dire je
connais pas le futur j'en sais rien
justement j'ai exclu rien en fait promis
on sent pas la vidéo sinon tu te
présente président de la République
il y a aussi une question qui se pose
justement quand on écrit ces textes
aujourd'hui on parlait un peu du rapport
avec les réseaux sociaux mais ce que
parfois on s'auto sans sur pas je veux
dire aujourd'hui peut vite y avoir des
polémiques tu vas écrire un texte ça va
heurter la sensibilité de tel ou telle
personne est-ce qu'on y pense avant
d'écrire qui avait tout le process il va
pouvoir répondre à ça
non je pense pas correl il
s'auto-censure il a on montre dans le
doc il a il a des notes dans son ordi où
il écrit absolument tout mais ça peut me
mettre des phrases qui sont pour un
futur personnage de méchant dans un film
donc il va dire les pires atrocités de
la terre donc il s'autorise tout après
est-ce que c'est le bon moment est-ce
que c'est la bonne chose à dire en fait
c'est ça qu'on que j'ai essayé de suivre
et de filmer c'est à quel moment après
tu fais le tri en disant ouais est-ce
que c'est bien dans une chanson en fait
dehors je crois que c'est ça qui te qui
te dirigeait quoi est-ce que c'est parce
que c'est un truc que j'ai déjà fait
est-ce que ça vaut le coup d'être
impertinent en ce moment tu vois le le
climat de la création de l'album c'était
quand même covid gilet jaune ça et tout
donc est-ce que j'ai envie d'être
impertinent à ce moment-là mais je pense
pas que tu penses à la censure à
l'auto-social qu'est-ce qu'on va dire de
ça non je monte au sens ouais c'est
exactement ça je pense pas à ça tu veux
juste conscient à peu près parce que je
laisse quand même des trucs qui je sais
que clairement mal interprété vont faire
des polémiques tu vois mais dans le dans
un cadre que que
tu te fixes un cadre en disant bon bah
voilà si je dis ça ça peut être oui mais
le derrière pas de comment dire je
m'empêche pas de dire les choses que
j'ai envie de dire tu vois et puis de
toute façon qu'est-ce que c'est des
polémiques maintenant tu peux tu vas
avoir 15 articles on sait même pas si
les gens les lisent il y a des je te
jure il y a des articles des fois je
vois il y a genre deux lecteurs et
comment tu vis justement à
à l'ère de la polémique de la petite
phrase quand on est artiste que mon toi
tu vis ça
et après à se poser de questions est-ce
que c'est comme ça en fait et je pense
que
moi une méthode de travail qui fait que
souvent je laisse reposer les choses ça
veut dire j'ai du recul je sors pas je
sors pas des morceaux du jour au
lendemain sur
un coup de un coup de sang tu vois je
dis pas carte techniquement ce serait
pas intéressant c'est juste c'est pas
comme ça que je fais donc j'ai le temps
de me poser les questions je sais je
sais quand même exactement grosso modo
ce que j'écris après je peux me tromper
tu vois mais je sais comment ça peut
être interprété par qui je vois à peu
près le truc et après c'est un choix
d'artistes ou je me dis justement c'est
cette époque peut-être qui est pas la
même qu'à tes débuts il y a peut-être
plus de liberté dans les textes d'autres
vont dire que c'est mieux parce que on
est leader certaines personnes je crois
pas je crois pas qu'il y avait plus de
liberté dans les textes avant je veux
dire quand on voit ça c'est sortait gare
au Gorée il avait des galères quand
Gainsbourg il sortait la Marseillaise en
reggae des galères
et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple par exemple tu sors la
Marseillaise en reggae tu es tranquille
limite ils vont le chanter au stade de
foot tu vois donc je pense que justement
j'ai pas envie c'est pour ça c'est que
des fois j'ai du mal à parler de ces
sujets là de politique et tout parce que
j'ai pas envie de dire qu'on est dans
une époque pire qu'avant pour plein de
raisons notamment parce que ça va
contribuer à ce que les gens disent on
est dans une époque percant c'est juste
différent et oui des sujets qui vont
faire des polémiques des fois c'est mal
des fois c'est bien il y a aussi le côté
au genre de toute façon on peut
s'exprimer je veux dire si demain une
polémique sur un de mes textes je peux
aussi choisir de l'expliquer souvent je
choisirais de ne pas faire attention tu
vois ce que je veux dire je trouve pas
qu'on soit dans une période non plus
je trouve dans la période actuelle c'est
juste
en fait ça dépend aussi c'est toi qui te
fixe tes trucs ça dépend qu'est-ce
qu'une polémique intéressante que à
partir du moment où
en fait moi je lis pas trop les est-ce
que c'est la petite phrase le petit bout
de texte que vous vous êtes dans les
médias moi je suis pas dans les médias
je regarde pas ça m'intéresse pas donc
au final pour moi il y a pas de
polémique il y en a eu en plus des
petits trucs sur les dans l'album et
tout on va toujours essayer de chercher
t'isole n'importe plein de trucs du doc
et tout ça peut concrètement faire des
polémiques mais vu que je les vois pas
pour moi c'est pas des je sais pas
comment dire qu'est-ce qui pourrait
après c'est quoi le risque de de perdre
du public tu vois ok je sais pas
franchement j'ai pas je suis pas en
train de me dire on peut plus rien dire
etc quoi parce qu'en fait moi je trouve
quand même que je suis assez libre dans
mes morceaux et tout quoi et dans tes
morceaux justement il y a il y a une
anecdote que j'ai envie que tu nous
raconte parce qu'elle est incroyable un
jour tout ton ordinateur moi ça me parle
parce que toutes mes interviews je les
ai écrit aussi sur mes notes et là il y
a plus rien et là c'est c'est dingue
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que tu
peux un peu nous raconter ce moment-là
une demi-journée de hyperactivité parce
qu'on décide de les retrouver une
demi-journée d'abattement parce que je
dis waouh je suis en plein milieu de mon
album j'ai tout écrit et comment je vais
faire et le lendemain en fait il fait
presque abstraction du truc et il dit
bon bah vas-y on va faire autrement en
fait tant pis et après ce qu'un truc
un peu de SAS ou il dit non mais ça n'a
pas existé en fait j'avais j'ai jamais
eu de note en fait je vais prendre un
crayon je vais repartir on va repartir à
l'ancienne et tout c'est peut-être un
signe tu vois genre souvent
allez on y va et tout et en fait tu
arrives vachement à aller de l'avant et
tout ça je trouve ça ouf
comment comment tu vis ce moment-là
parce que c'est que au début j'y croyais
pas trop en fait j'ai perdu genre j'ai
perdu des tonnes et des tonnes de notes
mais quand je dis des tonnes de notes
c'est vraiment comme ça que je travaille
et genre il y avait des
des idées de scénario de films il y
avait des idées de dialogues il y avait
plein de morceaux il y avait plein de
morceaux en cours ça représente
peut-être des 10000 pages de notes tu
vois et au moment où je l'ai perdu ben
j'avais du mal à y croire et en même
temps il y a une part de moi qui ai dit
tu savais que ça allait finir à arriver
parce que j'avais un ordi je voyais qui
j'avais jamais Redé en fait il était
tout le temps en veille et en fait en
gros un ordi au en fait un ordi c'est
resynchronisé dans le Cloud et c'était
un ordi où j'avais très peu de notes qui
s'est resynchronisé sur les le Cloud où
il y avait toutes mes notes il a comment
est-ce qu'on dit là genre il a écrasé
quoi il a écrasé voilà et du coup il y a
une part de moi qui me dirait tu savais
que ça allait finir par arriver il y a
un petit moment de panique genre le
moment dans le doc où j'appelle apple
moi je vois que je suis en panique je
suis en train un peu bégayer et tout ça
se voit pas tant que ça peut-être si tu
connais pas bien enrel ça se voit pas
tant que ça mais en fait ouais il est en
mais est-ce que vous c'est que il me
laisse filmer par contre quoi aucun
moment même là je me suis pas dit
il va peut-être me dire d'éteindre la
caméra quoi ça c'est ça c'est ouf c'est
là où là
et puis c'était tellement gros que les
mythes ça me faisait je sais pas comment
dire tu vois quand tu es dans des
émotions que tu contrôle pas et après en
fait j'ai limite en vrai je veux j'ai
fait le deuil du truc quoi je me suis
dit n'y pense même pas tu vas pas les
récupérer c'est foutu et là aujourd'hui
il y a un pick-up tu mets tout tu fais
attention
il y a pas de backup bah j'ai mon qui
est là au cas où pour récupérer
mes notes alors petite question qui se
pose Clément justement c'est escurane
saison 3 saison 3 alors saison 3
peut-être dans 10 15 20 piges peut-être
non tout de suite bah j'ai plat j'ai
vraiment j'ai plus de rush là j'ai plus
de j'ai plus rien en fait j'avais des
roches d'avance entre guillemets parce
que j'avais commencé à filmer
civilisations
pendant que je montais les autres
épisodes mais non là j'ai pas continué à
filmer on est arrivé au bout d'un truc
cool je pense que on a raconté un truc
qu'on comme on voulait le raconter pour
l'instant les gens ont bien adhéré et
tout donc on était hyper contents et
pour l'instant il faudrait correl et se
relance dans un énorme projet un truc
qui l'a jamais fait ou peut-être ça me
referait qui fait de le filmer mais pour
l'instant il n'a pas de saison 3
l'année prochaine genre rendez-vous en
octobre un petit sentiment de boucle
boucré de on est en plus en plus on est
content de ce qu'on avec parce qu'en
fait en plus moi c'est ce que les quatre
épisodes qu'on a fait là et quand je dis
on c'est avec l'équipe Christophe
Einstein avec qui j'ai co réalisé les
monteurs Hugo Maël et toute l'équipe
ouais c'est ça et en fait c'était ce
qu'on voulait faire à la base c'était
montrer comment Aurel boss et écrit et
du coup il a fallu les 6 épisodes
l'année dernière pour qu'on rencontre
Aurel qu'on le raconte qu'on ne
connaisse mieux
connaître à Blaye scred qui sont les
mecs qui l'entourent phases qui a un
musicien avec lui et maintenant on
pouvait rentrer un processus de création
donc en fait je suis arrivé là où je
voulais où je voulais arriver donc
maintenant il y a pas de saison 3 aussi
vraiment il y a une saison 3 en octobre
2023 qui sort elle sera pas ouf et dites
le moi dites-le
je pense que ce serait pas une bonne
idée du tout quoi ça me fait un peu
comme quand on a fait bloquer qu'au bout
de parce que Clem il écrivait avec nous
sur bloqué quand on a fait bloquer on
arrive à 120 épisodes on a fini le truc
on s'est c'était bien le package
pour apprendre on sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver peut-être on va avoir une
idée on va essayer [ __ ] les mêmes mecs
à 60 piges qu'est-ce que ça donne c'est
pourquoi pas mais en tout cas par
exemple bloqué je pense à comme exemple
parce que on nous demande tous les mois
d'en refaire tu vois
dans d'autres contextes en parodie un
truc mais il y a tellement aussi de
comment dire il y a eu des fois des
reboot des remakes des des suites de
séries dont on a été fans qui au final
aurait bien on aurait bien aimé qu'elle
finisse au bon moment et là pour
l'instant pour moi c'est le bon moment
après on sait jamais où est sur pas dans
un projet énorme c'est un gros fan de
manga et on a plein d'exemples de mangas
notre manga nos manga préféré c'est slam
dunk tu vois c'est un manga il y a eu 30
je crois 34 tomes il y en a jamais eu un
de plus l'histoire elle est parfaite qui
touche plus tu peux le relire si tu veux
tu vas l'apprécier clairement au fil du
temps mais si elle faisait des nouveaux
épisodes je sais pas enfin en fait ça
dépend c'est la bonne idée le bon projet
la bonne histoire et que ça ait du sens
si tu le fais juste parce que tu es en
galère et je sais plus quoi faire ouais
il y a des chances que ça marche pas et
avant la saison 3 la 2 que les deux vont
pouvoir enfin que les gens vont pouvoir
découvrir bientôt donc merci à tous les
deux pour cette interview puis bonne
chance pour la suite merci à vous
[Musique]